[Music]
Parks and Rec you guys have do such a
funny show and such a a tight cast it
seems like you guys are in sync with
each other comedic ly probably off
camera as well as on yeah it's really a
dream job and sometimes I feel guilty
because we like each other so much and
yeah we often we like hang out together
we have dinner together we drink
together
we vacation together it's it's really go
on vacations together we have yeah we
have me and and Amy and Aubrey we try to
do like a girls or every plaza you guys
and what do you do you get together and
you just hang out hang out we drink a
couple drinks you know nightlife no we
usually sit in the bed all three of us
and watch TV together the three of you
get together and drink and hang out in
bed Cinemax
yes anything for ratings um but we often
play games like TV games like Amy taught
us this game mustache TV mustache TV yes
anybody played that before people know
basically what you do is you take a
mustache you can make one yourself you
can draw it on which is not good if
you're at a hotel and then you stick it
on the TV and you and you pray like
you're at a sporting event that somebody
will walk directly into that a character
will just walk into the mustache yes and
and it feels like you won or you did
something really great or they do try it
yeah I want to try they just before the
segment they told me you were I didn't
know what this was for but they brought
out these these mustache can you show us
how this works I'm just I'm gonna put it
I'm gonna put it on art yeah I'm gonna
put it on there okay and then for all of
us okay and you just go over to that
monitor where I look sickly come back
okay
I'm just gonna pick random places this
is not staged and then yeah is that kind
of ruin our TV because that's the only
one we can afford yeah you might have to
get it yes we got to take care of that
TV so you can just stick these to your
television yeah I mean be careful if
it's not your own television I would
cancel okay there you go you're just
gonna that's that's maybe a little
ambitious well okay thank you probably
be polish do something like that okay
okay this is gonna be challenging all
right can you see that monitor on TV you
can see it okay all right yeah well
there's one down here that's like
[Applause]
like I had a Brazilian
we live to be down here and you have to
be you've got to take this one here oh
that's hard oh wait a minute
oh that this is pretty
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes sure easily the Thomas show
for us that's really saying something
it's a good hamstring okay I want to
catch those please all right let's make
sure we get something to go back to them
leave it up this is creepy one down here
I'm just offended chairman do this guy
going we're gonna get to your film clip
in just a second
[Applause]
[Music]
they'll kill you
[Applause]
you